[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt's ein hammer leckeres rezept
ich werde chuck reed chip cookies machen
also diese typisch amerikanischen kekse
mit schokostückchen drinnen
ich kenne die aus meiner kindheit leider
nur aus dem supermarkt als und ich jetzt
amerika sondern diese american cookies
die man eigentlich überall bekommt die
sind aber etwas fester und knuspriger
aber trotzdem lecker und ich war heute
eine version wirklich super soft ganz
weit außen knusprig innen weich und es
sind wirklich die perfekten kekse
also gebt direkt los ich zeig euch
hätten die klassische variante und dann
machen wir sie noch einmal in veganer
variante denn vegan die kekse auch super
und daraus könnt ihr dann noch mal eine
torte backen und da gibt es eine
kopierte aber die die kommt dann noch
okay für die klassische version brauche
ich 225 gramm weiche butter 100 gramm
normalen zucker einen halben teelöffel
salz 240 gramm brauner zucker einen
teelöffel vanille extra zwei eier diesem
zimmer waren 350 gramm mehl jeweils
einen halben teelöffel natron und
backpulver 200 gramm schoko drops die
sind backfest und noch mal 70 für die
deko man muss schon sagen dass man hier
schon so vom mengenverhältnis her fast
eins zu eins zu eins fett zucker und
mehl hat aber dadurch werden die eben
auch außen knusprig und innen so richtig
soft und man muss dazu sagen bei so
einem keks sieht es immer so nach extrem
viel zucker und fett aus aber wenn ich
mir überlege es und mama kuchen der hat
auch 250 gramm butter 250 gramm zucker
etwas mehr mail als butter und zucker
aber trotzdem irgendwo muss alex marx
herkommen und ich meine es ist eine
süßigkeit was soll's wir es nicht die
ganzen kekse alleine aber nur so bekommt
ihr die konsistenz hin denn es ist
einfach so sobald ihr die zuckermenge
reduziert ist es halt so dass ihr diese
typischen eigenschaften nicht mehr habt
also nicht mehr außen knusprig innen
butterweich
das hat dann halt nicht mehr und ich
mich jetzt hier braunen und weißen
zucker weil ich dadurch wirklich diese
tollen eigenschaften habe und auch
diesen leicht nussigen geschmack aus dem
braunen zucker
also kommt jetzt hier die zimmer warme
butter in die schüssel alle zutaten sind
es immer warm salz und zucker
der braune circa hinterher und dann wird
die masse mit vanille extrakt erst mal
für vier bis fünf minuten
[Musik]
so sieht die masse perfekt aus jetzt
gebe ich einen nach dem anderen dazu und
riss auch schön ein
oh mann ich habe gedacht habe das schöne
prinz klima dabei habe ich total
bekleckert
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich mehl backpulver und
natron noch dazu so ein ganz normales
weizenmehl stinkt mir funktioniert aber
genauso gut an dem wir vielleicht noch
ein bisschen weniger weil dinkelmehl
einfach ein bisschen mehr feuchtigkeit
braucht
wie schlimm ist der schaden wie schlimm
ist es nicht so schön
und das meer wirklich nur ganz kurz
einrühren das war's schon
nein das war es noch nicht jetzt nämlich
noch die 200 gramm schokolade und da
habe ich die bank fest
die sind wirklich super bekommt ja auch
in jedem supermarkt und ich liebe zar
peter deswegen nämlich die so ist jetzt
also die konsistenz des teiges schön
fest und jetzt nehmt ihr euch einfach
wie wacklig benutzt die lochbleche da
trägt hier sogar gerne um dann habe ich
einfach eine schöne glatte fläche ohne
rand ausfalls der keks doch mal etwas
größer will dann wird er am rand nämlich
auch richtig schön und jetzt guckt mag
ich habe eis portionierer in drei größen
mit dem größten eis portionierer bekommt
ihr richtig große cookies hin
die mache ich jetzt heute nicht aber
könnt ihr auch machen und mit dem
mittleren eis portionierer finde ich
habe dir die perfekte kugel größe und
mit dem kleinen habt ihr so kleinere
cookies die zum beispiel ganz gut als
torten dekoration funktionieren so mache
ich nämlich auch noch ein paar für meine
torte die ich dann noch bankenwerte
und jetzt wirklich dran denken viel
abstand lassen denn die zerlaufen ja
noch im backofen mit der backzeit müsst
ihr echt ein bisschen variieren also ich
mache es so ich habs jetzt natürlich
schon getestet und ich habe es so
gemacht ich habe jetzt einfach mal einen
cookie drauf habe ihn dann im ofen
gebacken und habe einfach geguckt ob
beim er am backofen 190 grad ober
unterhitze perfekt sind oder ob ich doch
180 brauche wie viele minuten denn der
kuki soll er wirklich schön braun werden
nicht zu dunkel ihnen noch etwas
matschig sein und da müsste dann einfach
einen test cookie machen und dann
individuell mit eurem backofen abstimmen
weil jeder backofen bagdad anders aber
ich weiß bei mir jetzt schon und ich
habe natürlich bei den großen und
kleinen eine andere backzeit und so
können dass sie dann einfach testen
jetzt nehme ich noch diese
zurückgelegten schoko drops denn ich
möchte dass auch die oberfläche voll ist
denn das kann man immer nicht so ganz
bestimmen soll schon sowieso zufällig
aussehen aber wir überlassen sind nicht
dem zufall und dann drücke ich hier noch
ein paar drauf und dann dürfen sie schon
einen backofen und bei mir ist es so die
großen also die mit dem mittleren eis
portionierer brauchen bei mir im
backofen etwa acht minuten und die
kleinen etwa sechs minuten
[Musik]
und die öfen müssen vorgeheizt sein
für die veganen cookies habe ich jetzt
einfach vegane butter da gibt's auch
mittlerweile echt ganz gute alternativen
zur herkömmlichen butter auf kokos basis
wandel basis auch auf soja basis ich
habe jetzt hier eine butter auf kokos
basis zucker bleibt gleich alle anderen
zutaten bleiben gleich und stadtteil
könnt ihr jetzt entweder apfelmus
verwenden oder einfach leinsamen und
wasser dem nämlich beide wirklich auch
ganz tolle eigenschaften
ich mache jetzt einfach halb halb das
heißt ich bereite jetzt einmal den teig
zu halten das ganze nehmen für die eine
hälfte apfelmus wie die andere hälfte
leinsamen dann kann man nämlich auch
probieren wie der unterschied schmeckt
und ich habe auch hier die tat bitter
schokoladen drops denn die sind schon
von natur aus vegan also wirklich keine
milch enthalten
bei den meisten steht zwar auf der
verpackung darauf kann spuren von milch
und so weiter enthalten
das liegt aber nur daran dass es in der
produktionshalle durch eine straße läuft
und eigentlich hat es wirklich damit
milch keinen kontakt aber sie müssen uns
drauf schreiben einfach aus rechtlichen
gründen
das heißt hier ist die zubereitung
gleich was ich jetzt aber schon
vorbereiten werde ist
leinsamen ist jetzt wirklich im ganzen
verwenden also die sehen so aus und die
werden jetzt fein zermahlen und
gemahlene leinsamen also geschrotete
leinsamen nehmt ihr bitte nicht denn da
sind schon die wertvolle öle und fette
und die wichtigen bestandteile
rausgezogen die ich eben jetzt auch
dafür braucht das sich als ersatz habe
jetzt kann ich hier die leinsamen
schroten entweder erst mal die leinsamen
schroten dann mit wasser vermischen oder
einfach direkt mit dem wasser
und dann muss ich die leinsamen
mischungen etwa 15 minuten stehen lassen
aber die zeit nutze ich um schon mal den
übrigen tag vorzubereiten
so sieht das ganze jetzt aus ihr seht
noch recht flüssig und es lasse jetzt
wie gesagt ganz kurz stehen zum quellen
bereit ihr den teig zu das heißt butter
zucker salz vanille extrakt und braunen
zucker wirklich schön wieder cremig
rühren und dann sehen wir uns gleich
wieder zur weiteren verarbeitung die
butter zucker mischung seht jetzt exakt
gleich aus wie vorhin und jetzt nehmt
ihr entweder apfelmus als ersatz und
stellt so den teig fertig oder wie
gesagt diese leinsamen und macht damit
den teig fertig ich zeige jetzt beides
deswegen halte ich den teig damit ich
einfach später den vergleich habe ich
meinen die ein oder andere zutat
irgendwas von beidem hat man eigentlich
zu hause oder kann man sich besorgen und
dann habt ihr wirklich wunderbar ein
tolles weggangs rezept und dann habe ich
jetzt hier einmal die menge kann hier
apfelmus dazu geben also gern auch
einfach mit der küchenmaschine oder
einem handrührgerät weiter rühren mehl
backpulver natron dazu ich habe die
zutaten jetzt auch schon halbiert also
nicht wundern und die schokolade rein
perfekt apfelmus cookies und die
leinsamen
[Musik]
und aus beiden tagen werde ich jetzt
einfach direkt wieder die gleichen
cookies herstellen ganz wichtig ist dass
die cookies nach dem backen wirklich
schön abkühlen dürfen das heißt holz aus
dem ofen rausstellte auf die
arbeitsplatte lasse abkühlen und dann
werden sie erst vom blech
heruntergenommen damit sie nämlich nicht
brechen denn nach dem backen sind sie
wirklich ganz weich wie kuchen müssen ab
kühl und dann bekommen sie die schöne
feste konsistenz also bis gleich
[Musik]
hier habe ich jetzt die fertigen kekse
wie gesagt gut abkühlen lassen und dann
erst vom blech lösen und ich finde rein
optisch sind sie alle richtig schön am
besten gefallen mir optisch die von der
farbe her das sind die klassischen
wahrscheinlich durch sei die haben
einfach zu diesem gelben ton die mit
apfelmus finde ich aber auch mega gut
weil sie so eine schöne struktur haben
die mit leinsamen die sehen ein bisschen
aus wie hafer kekse finde ich weiß es so
ein bisschen flach sind aber wir machen
gleich die geschmacks borenich probiert
mal ganz kurz und dann hole ich gleich
noch einen veganer den ball kann der
darf nämlich die zwei veganen probieren
und dann habe ich noch meine freundin
die sabine die macht dann auch eine
blindverkostung das heißt ich stellte
dann auch die zutaten weg und dann sage
ich gar nicht was das ist und die
probieren dann einfach und bewerten
also die klassischen cookies
klasse rickys gießen so letta vor allem
außen schön knusprig und innen in der
mitte fans oft bei den apfel cookies
finde ich hört man schon dass die
bisschen größer sind aber auch nicht
schlecht echt gut also diesen außen
richtig knusprig testfahrt machen
hmm und jetzt noch die mit leinsamen und
die fühlen sich schon weiter an so
bisschen kuchen ähnlicher also apfelmus
cookies sind kekse und die leinwand
cookies sind kuchen ähnlicher weicher
ich bin beide gut vielleicht nimmt man
einfach leinsamen und apfelmus ja okay
ich hoffe dass meine verkosten und dann
wird probiert
[Musik]
ok sowie mehr wolken herzlich willkommen
in meiner küche saison für heute nacht
karaoke kalk ja ihr müsstet ihr dürft
jetzt ich hab dachte ich das okay also
ich hab cookies gebacken
ihr dürfte alle drei mal probieren
volkan nur zwei dicke wolken die zwei
und es wurde die 3 und dann könnt ihr
mir einfach mal euer feedback geben wie
sie euch schmecken
ihr könnt doch ein ganzes nehmen könnte
sowas zum geschmack zum unterschied oder
sowas
oder was ich am besten kann
soft
sonne
die fand ich jetzt nicht so viel
wenn es oft besser als christ ich finde
es oft so dass geht das löst im mund
nehmen also ich mich welche am meisten
das ist unfair ja eigentlich hab ich ja
schon verraten dass die nicht begangen
somit eigentlich zuerst testen und dann
wollte ich bin so gerät egal was hat
dich nicht beeinflusst oder gar nicht
alle drei essen ja also das sind so die
klassischen chip cookies die sind
stadtteil mit apfelmus und diesen
stadtteil mit leinsamen nicht dass der
uli hat deswegen sind die bisschen weich
und die ist ein bisschen kritisch mit
der solinger aber wenn das komplett
gelöscht das ist ja schokolade
schokolade also ich finde dass wir noch
die ganz klassischen sind so vom
geschmack her und so von der konzern
sehr einfach wie man es kennt ja aber
ich finde man alternativen organe butter
und dann kommt ja und ich würde euch
zuhause raten wenn er die veganen macht
dann mischt am besten apfelmus und
leinsamen also weg so halbe portionen
von allem weil dann habt ihr hier noch
bisschen außen so dieses knusprige aber
das weiche von den leinsamen ich glaube
wenn man die wird dann ist es perfekt
java seien ja aber das ist echt und
damit schwierigen geschmackstest ja
danke freunden zu hause
ich wünsche ihnen noch machen cool
die menge an land doch gesund da
ballaststoffreich rekord also viel spaß
beim nachmachen und seid gespannt drauf
denn aus diesen keksen werde ich bald
eine torte backen und alle rezepte weber
ins wallis weltec oder ihn aufs eis -
blog.de
dankeschön herzlich willkommen in meiner
keks werkstatt und angst
[Musik]